sit with him I was at a big Ferrari
Porsche guy and I was at Ferrari and I
get allocated cars and they have the
sf90 spider in the super rare and the
guys like yeah the allocation ends today
and so I'm there I'm talking to Rogan I
was like yeah you know it's the highest
car I'd ever have to pay for he's like
wait what is on the sf9 he's like man I
love an all black one I'm like really
he's like yeah uh give a guy doing like
I'm here with the fry guy so I'm like
hold on let me talk to him and talk to
him he's like we have one allocation
left and I was like hey they can do it
he's like I'll take it and just there
he's like you you get one too I'm like
yeah dude I'm the one who gave you the
idea